[Music]
I've always wondered why in a nation so
rich are some people so poor to me it's
always seemed so old-fashioned
like governments that don't resemble a
democracy or voting rights that don't
include women or like these wool
cardigans things that just shouldn't
exist
growing up I often ask myself this
question why does poverty still exist as
a daycare provider my mother made enough
money for us to live just above the
poverty line
despite providing a critical service to
society she stressed every day about
whether we have enough to pay for rent
or buy groceries she'd work more and
more hours just to escape being poor as
if it were a privilege she had to earn
to me that just didn't seem right the
truth about poverty and inequality in
the u.s. is far worse than my own
childhood might have indicated in the
United States one out of every five
children live in absolute poverty a
poverty rate higher than what prevails
in virtually all other rich nations
inequality in the u.s. is the highest
it's been since 1928
right before the Great Depression over
the past 35 years
the real average income of the top point
zero one percent has grown by three
hundred and twenty-two percent while
that of the bottom 90% has largely
remained stagnant in the American dream
of working hard and finding a way out of
poverty no longer applies increasingly
the greatest predictor of your future
success is not your education or your
perseverance
but your parents income and your race to
make matters worse economists now say
that inequality is so large that it's
had a negative impact on an overall
economic growth something we can all
care about people are poor absolutely
relatively and permanently and all at a
cost to our nation's growth so what can
we do about two years ago after reading
everything I could find to understand
poverty and inequality better and what
we can do to address it I stumbled
across a book it's called utopia for
realist by Rutger Bregman in the book he
chronicles an idea one so simple I
thought it couldn't possibly work it's
an idea that dates back 500 years to
Thomas More in his own book called
utopia some refer to it as the citizens
dividend others call it a basic income
so what is it it's an unconditional
monthly cash grant enough to pay for
your basic needs food shelter education
that's it it's not a favor but a right
as divisive as it might seem its action
ideas supported by individuals across
the political spectrum from civil rights
activists dr. Martin Luther King jr. who
praised it for its fairness to
free-market economist Milton Friedman
who appreciated how it instilled freedom
of choice now when I tell people we
should just give free money to everyone
they usually say you socialist and then
they respond with one of three concerns
people will spend it on drugs and
alcohol people will stop working we
can't afford to pay for it so today
I hope to share what I learned about
each of these three concerns and
hopefully show that a basic income is
more than just an idea it's a proven
idea number one people will spend it on
drugs and alcohol the underlying
assumption with this concern stated
bluntly is that there are somehow
something wrong with poor people poor
people make poor decisions like doing
drugs and alcohol and that's probably
why the poor to begin with because of
this mindset the approach has always
been the same if we could just teach
them if we could teach them how to live
life with our values in our culture if
they would only just listen what this
mindset fails to recognize are the
drastic effects of living in poverty
some poor people make poor decisions
because they're poor however if you
change the context you can change the
actions too World Bank researchers found
that in nineteen different cash transfer
programs across ten different nations
spending on alcohol and cigarettes went
down given hope and a brighter future
individuals stopped using temptation
goods as a way to cope with their
current situation instead the extra cash
went to pay for their kids school fees
to buy medicine to repair their homes to
invest in their small businesses to
further grow their wealth as Bregman
concluded poverty is not the result of
poor decision-making or lack of moral
character poverty is a lack of cash
number two people will stop working in
the 1970s there's a basic income
experiment in a small town in Canada
every family received enough money to
ensure they were lift above the poverty
line and for four years all went well
until a new Canadian government was
voted into power that immediately ended
the
Behrman 25 years later a Canadian
professor found and analyzed these
records and the results were clear
school performance went up while mental
health complaints domestic violence
incidents and hospitalization rate all
went down and no one quit their jobs the
only ones who worked a little less were
new mothers caring for their child and
students who decided to stay in school
longer which brings me to the third and
final concern even if this is all true
we can't afford to do it actually we
can't afford not to do it
poverty is extremely expensive the cost
of child poverty in the u.s. is
estimated at five hundred billion
dollars in terms of higher health care
costs higher dropout rates and more
crime this is an incredible waste of
human potential a basic income could be
financed with what's known as a negative
income tax credit which essentially
means that your income is topped up as
soon as you fall below the poverty line
under this scenario according to
economists best estimates for cost of
one hundred and seventy five billion
dollars less than one percent of GDP
less than four percent of our nation's
annual budget we could actually
eradicate poverty as bregman No
basic income is like venture capital for
the people we invest now and after 10 to
20 years they'll pay for itself in terms
of lower healthcare costs less crime and
more productive citizens putting the
money to work and stimulating our
economy according to current estimates a
basic income started today would result
in an increase of GDP of 13 percent by
2025 or 2.5 trillion dollars so when
given cash people spend less on drugs
and alcohol work just as much and we
actually save and generate money well if
all this is so obviously true why
haven't we done it already the truth is
we tried in the late 1960s we piloted a
basic income for close to nine thousand
individuals across seven different
states and by every measure as you might
have guessed by now the pilot was a
success except for one researchers found
that for those families receiving a
basic income divorce rates increased by
50% now this was something politicians
of the time just cannot get behind a
basic income had apparently given women
too much independence however just ten
years later in a reanalysis of the data
researchers found that this was a
statistical error but by that time the
political moment had passed now we are
seeing a reemergence of the basic income
Silicon Valley has taken up the idea
based on fear that robots will one day
take our jobs however while the future
is uncertain the present is clear
poverty exists where and when it
shouldn't we need to rid ourselves of
the bye seas we have about the poor we
need to acknowledge the wealth
we have to address the problem and the
potential that we will unlock if we do
so we need to redefine our social
contract to say that no one will live in
poverty but to do this most of all we
need the will and that will must be
founded on the belief that a life
without poverty should not be a
privilege if to earn but a right that we
all deserve
[Applause]
[Music]